PROFESSOR: Welcome
to this recitation
on damped harmonic oscillators.
So here you're asked to
assume an unforced, overdamped
spring-mass-dashpot that
started at x dot of 0
equals to 0, so rest,
and to show that it never
crosses the equilibrium
position, x equal to 0, for t
larger than 0.
The second part of
the problem asks
you to show that regardless
of the initial condition,
this overdamped
oscillator can not
cross the equilibrium position
more than one time, or more
than once.
OK.
So why don't you
pause the video,
try to think about this
problem, and I'll be right back.
Welcome back.
So the system that
we're looking at
is a spring-mass-dashpot
that would
be written in this form-- second
order differential equation.
Let's assume that we have
positive constant coefficients
here.
And basically, to
solve this, you
would be considering the
methods that we saw before.
And the general
solution would just
be written in the form of
c_1 exponential lambda_1,
the c_2 exponential lambda_2,
with c_1, c_2 just two
constants that
would be determined
by the initial condition.
Lambda_1, lambda_2
would be here the roots
of the characteristic
polynomial that you
would have found there.
Given that we're looking
at an overdamped, unforced
spring-mass-dashpot,
you can actually
show that lambda_1
and lambda_2 would
be both real and negative.
And here, we can just
say that basically,
lambda_1 and lambda_2
would be less than 1.
And we'll keep that aside for
now, and I'll use this later.
So this is just
setting up the problem.
So now, what was the question?
The question was to show that
if we start this system with
initial condition x
dot of 0 equal to 0,
which corresponds to
lambda_1*c_1 plus lambda_2*c_2
equals to 0, then the system
cannot cross the equilibrium
position x equal to 0
for t larger than 0.
So let's just start by assuming
that the system crosses
the equilibrium position.
So for example, let's look for
t-star such that x of t-star
is equal to 0.
So x of t-star, we
know its form already.
We have the general
form of x of t-star.
That's basically c_1 exponential
lambda_1*t-star plus c_2
exponential lambda_2*t-star.
And so we can massage
this equation,
and basically end up with
minus c_2 over c_1 equal
to exponential of lambda_1
minus lambda_2*t-star.
So now let's just
find our t-star
by applying the log of both
sides of this equation.
So we get t-star equals to
the log of minus c_2 over c_1,
and we divide by the
lambda_1 minus lambda_2.
So here this tells us that if
t-star exists, which means,
if the log is defined, and
this minus c_2 over c_1
basically is positive, then we
only have one value of t-star
possible.
So here, we actually are
answering the second part
of this question,
number two, which
was telling us that regardless
of the initial condition-- so
regardless of the
coefficient c_1,
c_2 that we would
have-- if t-star exists,
there is only one.
And so that means that
the system would not
cross this equilibrium
position more than once.
But I'll come back on that.
But now let's go back
to what we were asked
to do in the first part,
where we basically now go back
to our x dot of 0 equals to
0, which basically gave us
that minus c_2 over c_1 is
equal to lambda_1 over lambda_2,
and the way we defined
lambda_1 over lambda_2
here gives us that minus
c_2 over c_1 is less than 1,
which means that the log
is going to be negative.
What happens in the denominator?
Lambda_1 minus lambda_2
would be positive.
So with this initial
condition, we
would end up with a t-star
that would be negative.
So basically, x is never equal
to 0 again for t larger than 0,
given these initial conditions.
So that finishes this
first part of the problem.
So I'll go back on the physics
of it in a moment with a graph.
So starting from this
initial condition,
x can never be equal to
0, because the only t-star
we can find would be negative.
So for t larger
than 0, it does not
cross the equilibrium point.
The second part of the
problem-- so this was one--
just comes from the fact
that, if I label this star,
star tells us that if minus
c_2 over c_1, strictly
larger than 0, then
only one t-star exists.
So if we have a solution,
there is only one.
And this is regardless
of the initial conditions
that we would be given.
So the system cannot cross the
equilibrium position more than
once.
So now let's look at what
we're doing here, graphically.
Let's assume that we're,
for example, starting
with initial
condition here, where
we're stretching our spring,
but we start with 0 velocity.
So x dot of 0 equal to 0.
That was the system that we had.
Then this is an overdamped
case where both basically
exponentials are
decaying to 0, and so we
would have a solution that
would go to 0 quickly.
It would be damped.
And so this would be part 1.
Now let's look at what
would happen if we started
with other initial conditions.
So for example, starting
from the same point
with a much bigger velocity.
Then the system would go up, but
eventually, it has to go down.
It wouldn't have this
shape, but basically, it
would have to go
down to 0's position.
And when it reaches,
you can show that again,
the derivative of x
can reach 0 only once.
And at that point, you're then
back to the initial conditions
that you had in the first
part of the question,
and so you can then, from here,
argue again that you cannot
cross the zero, the
equilibrium point,
after reaching a maximum.
Now what if we
had a stretch that
would be giving a
negative velocity
to the mass, and a very
strong negative velocity?
Then the system also wants to go
back to 0, but could overshoot.
And the overshoot would
also generate a unique time
at which the derivative
would be equal to 0,
and after that point, you would
be back to the same argument
we had before,
where the solution
would have to go toward
0, but never crosses it.
So we can have various
configurations.
And here I start
with this point,
but you could also start with
other initial conditions, where
you could have,
as well, something
that would be, for example,
a very strong positive,
where again, here you
would have an overshoot,
but then the solution would be
attracted by the x equal to 0
solution.
And of course you could also
start from the equilibrium.
If you're not imposing
any initial velocity,
you just stay there,
because this is not forced.
But if you're
imposing a velocity,
then you would have other
trajectories of the kind,
for example, like this, where
again, it would go up, but then
be attracted back
by the 0 solution.
So that's the typical behavior
for a damped oscillator, where
basically there's
no oscillation,
but the solution is
attracted to rest.
And you could have
cases of overshoot.
Then you can show that
after the overshoot,
velocity would
reach 0, at maximum,
and then would be attracted
back to the zero solution
with never crossing it.
And that ends this recitation.